et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
marc raynaud bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous midi chargé
des relations avec le parlement et la
participation citoyenne et vous êtes là
surtout en tant que soutien du candidat
emmanuel macron on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien marc fesneau il est
juste là c'est christophe gendry
directeur départemental de la nouvelle
république dans le loir-et-cher le
loiret cher c'est votre département
d'élection marc fesneau le précise pour
nos téléspectateurs bonjour christophe
et merci d'être avec nous marc fesneau
marine le pen à tenir son dernier
meeting c'était ta race sur ses terres
du pas de calais dès le début elle
attaque emmanuel macron elle est revenue
sur son attitude lors du débat d'entre
deux tours je la cite nonchalant
condescendant d'une arrogance sans
limite un président ne devrait pas se
tenir comme ça que répondez vous
si c'est assez intéressant devant le
changement de pied qui était siens en
sortant du débat mercredi elle a trouvé
que le débat était de bonne tenue qu'ils
avaient pu échanger des arguments et au
fond ne cherchant plus quel fils trouvé
pour expliquer un certain nombre de
sujets sur lequel effectivement adultes
en difficulté à répondre ou à donner à
mon sens en tout cas des réponses
crédibles elle a trouvé ce fil est un
fils de désormais la vie politique se
résumerait la façon dont on tient ses
mains dans ton tient ses bras donc on
porte le regard et dont on met son coude
c'est ce qu'on appelle rien d'autre
qu'un procès d'intention au fond c'est
parce qu'on aurait telle et telle
attitude on voudrait envoyer tel ou tel
message est alors c'est un débat donc un
débat c'est une confrontation une
confrontation si on n'est pas capable
d'accepter ce qu'elle a fait elle même
aussi dans le débat et je n'ai pas vu
l'arrogance ou d'agressivité dans ce
qu'elle avait dit non son attitude je
veux dire dans un débat il ya une
confrontation il on peut lever les
sourcils sans que ce soit quand même une
offense faite à son concurrent on peut
couper la parole sans que ce soit une
même trouver des arguments pour aller
contre ceux des zones d autres arguments
sans que ce soit une offense docu jeu il
ya quelque chose d'un peu vain d'essayer
de chercher des querelles là où il y en
a pas aidés chercher d'essayer de
chercher des attitudes la gestuelle de
sur la forme
qu'elle n'avait non j'ai des choses à
dire l attaque sur la forme ne l'ayant
pas fait mercredi n'ayant rien trouvé à
redire mercredi dans l'intervalle elle a
dû trouver des éléments de langage ou
des éléments d'angle et de l attaque sur
la forme parce que sur le fond est
manifestement elle se retrouvait en
difficulté sur l'ensemble des sujets sur
lesquels le président de la république a
essayé n'ont pas lui répondre à l
d'ailleurs mais de répondre aux français
parce que un débat c'est un débat de
confrontation d'idées de projets
contre-projet est ce que vous les
entendez quand même ces reproches qui
sont faits aussi par par certains
français sur l'attitude d'emmanuel mâcon
qui peut paraître arrogant qui peut
paraître déconner je les trouve injuste
alors je les entends je vois bien qu'ils
existent mais je les trouve injuste
parce que pour connaître le président la
république pour voir ce qu'ils nous
disent qu'ils nous demandent de faire
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres est ce que nous avons fait
depuis cinq ans je trouve qu'ils sont
injustes alors après comment dire il ya
toujours le sentiment est une chose et
donc il faut il faut aussi que
patiemment nous montrions ce qui veut
faire ce qu'il fait et quelles sont les
attitudes qui sont les siennes c'est là
aussi c'est une question d'angle et
d'attitude que les gens essaient de lui
faire porter moi je vois ce qu'il a fait
dans la crise des gilet jaune pour
essayer de répondre à la colère dans la
crise qu vite pour essayer de faire face
comment dire aux difficultés auxquelles
étaient confrontés les gens avec une
attitude en plus je vous prie de me
croire en conseil des ministres de
grande attention au cas très particulier
à la façon dont tout cela pourrait se
comprendre sur le terrain à la façon
dont ça pouvait se passer sur le terrain
nous avons un président de la république
et qui est très précis dans ses demandes
et très précis dans son attention aux
réalités que vivent nos concitoyens et
c'est bien ça qui compte quand on est
président de la république et j'ai
entendu d'ailleurs mercredi soir
adam le pen dire des choses qui me
paraissaient assez déconnecté sur des
tas de sujets de la réalité de nos
concitoyens on nomme même chemin
même sur le pouvoir d'achat d'ailleurs
failli ravir zouk et on va y revenir
mais est-ce que juste vous êtes inquiet
pencherait temps 10 mai pour avoir fait
quelques fois des exercices électoraux
il faut toujours être inquiet et
toujours être vigilant et donc faire
campagne jusqu'au dernier jour ce que
nous faisons les uns et les autres
nous sommes dans une société qui est
extrêmement éruptive donc tout événement
toute situation toute donnée nouvelle
peut faire des choses des effets parfois
de démobilisation alors certains disent
les choses sont faites alors évidemment
ça peut démobiliser moi je suis mobilisé
jusqu'au dernier jour jusqu'à la
dernière heure est donc par nature je
pars en plis dans le cou d'anxiété par
nature mais par nature dans une élection
je considère que jusqu'au dernier jour
et jusqu'à août dernier où il faut faire
campagne pour pour ceux qui s'apprêtent
à voter pour nous pour ceux qui croient
en nos idées pour ceux qui s'apprêtent à
voter pour nous pour pour faire en sorte
que madame le pen d'accès n'accède pas
au pouvoir il faut la vie politique et
la vie démocratique et nécessite de
faire campagne et j'ai sa part la crise
argent
le produit de cette présidentielle
confirmée l'importance du vote
contestataire de la réalité plus on
s'éloigne des centres urbains plus le
score de marine le pen progressé sa
mairie fille chez vous un marché noir la
commune où elle était mère puisque le 10
avril elle était en tête avec 29% des
voix dans le même temps
la cire construction où vous habitez le
député bercy jean luc mélenchon qui est
arrivé en tête comment faire pour y
consigner ces blocs que tout semble
opposer
si tout semble les opposer ces deux
masses et des matches il sait des
messages de différentes natures il n'est
pas nouveau que dans ma commune le front
national soit à un niveau élevé
c'est sait depuis longtemps que les
choses sont faites je vois dans le vote
rural encore que le vote rural dans
cette commune comme dans beaucoup de
communes du loir et cher le vote front
national a plutôt diminué ou a été
plutôt stabilisé
emmanuel macron progresse mais il ya un
vote je crois dans les territoires
ruraux qui est un vote d'inquiétude et
de sentiment d'abandon et de
délaissement qui n'est pas nouveau
d'ailleurs
et je dis que plus tôt dans notre
département c'est plutôt contenu puisque
c'était pas tout à fait c'est ce corps
là que vous avez une info ce n'est pas
un motif de satisfaction c'est justement
simplement une donnée mais je pense que
retisser le lien retisser la confiance
au rheu retisser le sentiment chez nos
concitoyens dans les territoires ruraux
qu'on essaye de s'attacher à faire en
sorte que des services publics que des
entreprises que l'anc décider du haut
débit puis se développer c'est un temps
long pour le faire et donc je pense
qu'on s'est mis sur ce chemin là grâce à
l'intervention et l activité très
éminente de jacqueline gourault sur ces
sujets là quand elle était ministre de
la cohésion du territoire je pense tous
à cette première partie de la réponse il
ya des territoires je pense dans le
vendômois je pense dans le blésois où
les citoyens ont pu voir la
réimplantation d'activité industrie pied
des territoires par exemple je pense au
sud du département qui ont été victimes
durablement
de difficultés industrielles et là aussi
il faut du temps long pour essayer
d'abord de reconstruire ce tissu
industriel et répondre aux attentes des
concitoyens après dans les territoires
urbains
loi comme ailleurs au fond je crois
qu'il ya une
une partie de ce vote est explicable
aussi par la volonté que nous portons un
regard particulier sur les questions de
transition écologique alors c'est vrai
que vous avez raison monsieur gendre et
ça pourrait paraître il réconcilie parce
que les questions idéologiques parfois
dans les territoires ruraux sont vécus
comme des agressions comme des
inquiétudes comme des risques
à la vie politique
il me semble que c'est d'essayer de
combiner parfois des dépositions
contradictoires en essayant de servir
l'intérêt général donc notre notre
obligation c'est d'essayer de répondre à
ces deux objectifs sont pas
incompatibles mais qui en apparence
peuvent l'être et justement puisque vous
parlez de saint marc fesneau je vous
redonne la parole christophe puisque
vous avez une question sur la hausse des
carburants oui
notamment elle pénalise ceux qui dans la
campagne loin parfois de leur lieu de
travail et pour qui les déplacements en
voiture sont une obligation faute de
transports en commun au delà des mesures
d'urgence actuelle le long terme qu'est
ce que vous leur proposez
alors d'avoir quand même les mesures
d'urgence si on permettait on a mis en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui permettent de contenir la hausse et
on peut espérer que ces dispositifs en
espérant qu'il soit plus court terme
possibles permettront de passer ce cap
qui est un cap difficile vous avez
raison pour un certain nombre de ceux
qui nous entendent ou qui nous regardent
ce matin vous êtes tenus par un fils
comme un fil à la patte par là le
véhicule le véhicule étant plutôt un
moteur à explosion diesel ou essence et
donc ça c'est une difficulté est donc
dans le court terme répondre à cette
question ce qu'on a commencé à faire et
ce qu'on a fait objectivement deuxième
élément c'est dans le cours et enfin
moyen et long terme c'est la transition
du parc 1 il n'y a pas d'autre solution
le président la république propose un
système de location de base qui
permettrait pour 100 euros par mois de
disposer d'une voiture électrique il ya
les recherches qui sont menées sur les
questions d'hydrogène je pense que alors
c'est une transition qu'il faut faire en
embarquant si nous permettaient ces
titres et c'est ce mot en embarquant des
citoyens à dire quelque chose qui ne
soit pas avec une commune comme une
impasse dans lesquelles on les mettrait
donc il faut qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
des nouveaux que nos concitoyens sont
face à ces difficultés faut qu'on les
accompagne dans la transition de la
motorisation pour dire les choses
simples on sait que cdc des véhicules
qui roulent parfois cher et donc c'est
là que l'état doit soit par des systèmes
de location soit par des systèmes des
dalles achat et d aider nos concitoyens
pour faire en sorte que cette transition
qui a d'abord un intérêt écologique soit
aussi et un intérêt aussi économique et
de pouvoir d'achat on peut pas
durablement ce n'est pas la première
fois que nous avons une crise pétrolière
la première crise pétrolière si j'ai
bonne mémoire c'était il ya 50 ans dans
73 et ça fait 50 ans qu'on on est dans
cette dépendance aux carburants et il
faut qu'on sorte là pour le coup
définitivement c'est d'ailleurs ce que
porte le président de la république
comme projet c'est de faire en sorte
qu'à terme nous ne soyons plus des pieds
de dépendants du carbone c'est une
question de pouvoir d'achat mais c'est
aussi une question évidemment d'écologie
transition écologique justement parler
de la hausse des carburants et est ainsi
la hausse des prix de l'énergie à la
hausse l'alimentaire les français 8
extrêmement préoccupés par leur pouvoir
d'achat ils ont de plus en plus de mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois est ce que
sur ces questions là ce n'est pas marine
le pen qui apparaît comme la candidate
des solutions concrètes plus qu'un
manuel maintenant c'est pas ce qui est
apparue me semble-t-il mercredi soir
c'est des solutions de facilité parce
que dans beaucoup de cas d'ailleurs elle
pose des questions de tva mais quand
vous avez une augmentation des prix la
tva c'est c'est pas indexée sur les prix
si je peux dire donc une fois que vous
êtes à votre 0 de tva mais n'avait pas
réglé les questions
là aussi le président de la république a
dit plus un certain nombre de choses je
pense à la question énergétique sur la
question du gaz il faut qu on est en
train de travailler avec nos partenaires
européens pour avoir une négociation
globale sur les tarifs du gaz pour faire
en sorte qu'on arrive à les contenir
voire on arrive à les baisser je ne
parle pas des questions moyen et long
terme convient d'évoquer avec christo
gendry sur la question de des carburants
pollet pour la voiture mais c'est un
élément évidemment sur la question de
l'alimentation on est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui les céréales qui sont
vendus sont pas des céréales et ont été
récoltés ces des céréales à venir c'est
le marché à terme si je peux dire le
stock c'est un stock de production à un
tarif c'est bon il ya aussi des gens qui
manifestement pas en france
particulièrement mais qui qui font un
peu de spéculation pour pas dire
beaucoup et ça aussi froid qu'on regarde
les mécanismes de régulation donc c'est
là dessus qu'il faudra qu'on essaie de
jouer c'est faire en sorte que nous
puissions retrouver une production on a
pas on a pas de risque quantitatif dans
notre pays on a des risques qualité et
puis après on fait ce que ce qu'il ya
des mécanismes d'indexation automatique
que ce qu'on a fait par exemple sur le
smic que c'est peut-être pas assez le cc
de l'indexation des salaires pour faire
en sorte que cette indexation permettent
de rattraper les effets de l'inflation
on a aussi des effets sur les
entreprises on va dire les choses que
sur parme sur dans mon département comme
dans beaucoup d'autres la question des
prix des matériaux sains effet pour les
chefs d'entreprise et puis ça un effet
pour ceux qui commandent auprès des
chefs d'entreprise dans la construction
là on est en train de regarder avec nos
partenaires aussi européen pour faire en
sorte que ce moment de crise c'est vrai
qu'elle avait démarré cette crise dongo
de hausse des matières premières avant
la crise ukrainienne la priorité c'est
quand même qu'on arrive à stabiliser des
choses sur le territoire ukrainien si je
peux dire avec les russes pour faire en
sorte que cette crise ne dut ne
s'inscrivent pas trop dans la durée mais
on voit bien que les chiffres évidemment
ne manquent pas nous inquiéter donc à la
question de la modération de ses
affaires de prix d'éviter des phénomènes
de spéculation puis par yahia la
question salariale
évoquer le président de la république en
question en termes de pouvoir d'achat et
vous parlez de la hausse des céréales
christophe à une question un peu comme
axa sa oui qu'est-ce que connexes mais
la hausse des céréales a parfois des dix
échecs le grand public ne méconnaît au
sujet de la chasse a suivi et c'est bien
c'était osé syrien le vent chili les
remboursements de dégâts de gibier par
les fédérations de chasseurs dans le sud
notamment certaines sont serait au bord
de la faillite est-ce qu'il
doit diviser les agriculteurs si jamais
elle devait faire défaut alors la
question simple réponse assez simple le
gouvernement dans ce banc cadre de son
plan de résilience a dit qu'ils allaient
compenser le surcoût qui seraient liées
au delta liées à l'indemnisation parce
que le prix des céréales a augmenté
parce que si on sait très bien et vous
le savez très bien vous aussi que ce
soit gendry qu' on peut mettre les
fédérations des chasseurs avec un nombre
de dégâts équivalents dans situation de
défaut de paiement parce que c'est
simplement l'indemnisation qu'augmente
compte tenu du prix des céréales le
poème il s'est engagé devant les
chasseurs à faire en sorte que nous
puissions compensée dans cette période
là c'est dans ce moment là seulement les
dégâts de gibier il ya je crois cet
après midi à l'assemblée générale des
chasseurs dans le loir-et-cher et
j'imagine que ce sera au coeur des
débats même si malheureusement je
pourrais pas y être mais évidemment le
gouvernement s'est engagé parce que là
on voit bien qu'on est d'abord dans
quelque chose de conjoncture est là
aussi on est des sujets de conjoncture
et donc le gouvernement a été au
rendez-vous et explicitement il est
indiqué que sur ces sujets là le
gouvernement sera au rendez vous
une autre willy votre question les
collectivités locales redoutent d'être
le prix est juste lors des baisses
d'impôts promises par le candidat
mettront alors qu'est ce que vous dites
ou mer ou aux présidents
d'intercommunalités départements de
région tous ces élus locaux qui
s'inquiètent je le redis qu'il suffit de
regarder ce que nous avons fait depuis
cinq ans et qu'ils n'ont jamais été la
variable d'ajustement contrairement
d'ailleurs au quinquennat avec un ace un
précédent
les collectivités n'ont pas été les
variables d'ajustement j'étais encore
l'autre jour en haute vienne je connais
assez bien ces sujets là comme vous le
savez je suis resté conseiller municipal
et conseiller communautaire
l'état était au rendez vous des demandes
des collectivités y compris pour
compenser les pertes de recettes qui
avait lieu au moment de la crise qu i
donc lui n'est pas question que les
collectivités
soit les l'épeule les enfants sacrifiés
si je peux dire des jusqu en rapport
avec ça qu'est ce que vous dites aux
français parce qu emmanuel macron a
redit mercredi soir lors du débat que
l'une de ses plus grandes mesures de
pouvoir d'achat c'était la baisse de la
taxe d'habitation la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation sauf que vous voyez
dans de nombreuses collectivités les
élus sont obligés d'augmenter la taxe
foncière est ce que ils ne sont pas
obligés de reprendre génial mais j'ai
donné la taxe d'habitation je ne trouve
pas un élu qui n'explique pas que vous
globalement la taxe d'habitation a été
compensée à l'euro l'euro après moi j'ai
été élu local quand quand on a produit
des hausses d'impôts locaux on le
faisait en conscience parce que c'était
parce qu'on en avait besoin
et donc faux pas on est dans un pays où
on a plutôt fait quand on a une décision
impopulaire de dire c'est pas moi c'est
l'état c'est un peu comme la sphère
européenne vous savez quand ce qu'on
nous n'avons pas fait nous pendant cinq
ans c'est à dire que quand ça va bien
c'est la france conserve à mal c'est la
faute de l'europe et parfois dans la
relation avec les collectivités cancer
est bien c'est grâce aux collectivités
quand ça va mal c'est que c'est à cause
de l'état l'état a mis beaucoup de
moyens sur la table je le répète y
compris pour compenser des pertes de
ressources y compris pour compenser un
certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels
des collectivités hanter en en
difficulté ça veut dire d'ailleurs qui a
besoin dernier entre l'état et les
collectivités je rappelle qu'en espagne
attendez j'appelle non je n'ai pas de
leçon à donner aux élus jeudi qu'on doit
on les élus prennent leurs
responsabilités quand ils augmentent les
impôts c'est parce qu'ils en ont besoin
et que c'est
certainement pas puisque la taxe
d'habitation est compensée à l'euro
l'euro donc il faut intellectuellement
c'est pas mal dans la vie politique et
ça participe aussi du débat démocratique
d'avoir une forme d'un thé le doigté
intellectuelle personne ne peut dire que
la taxe d'habitation n'a pas été
compensé après que ya des collectivités
qui ai besoin pour telle ou telle raison
il ya un sujet si on veut être précis
l'augmentation des matériaux
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
s'impose une difficulté aux
collectivités et particuliers
d'où la nécessité de bien réfléchir sur
la question de l'autonomie c'est pour ça
que j'ai ça en espagne ils sont tout à
fait autonome fiscalement l'état n'a
rien donné aux collectivités donc
l'autonomie voyait là ses limites parce
qu'on peut pas être autonome
quand ça va bien et demandé le soutien
de l'état quand ça va mal donc moi je
pense qu'il faut être pragmatique
alors l'état est au rendez vous et on
voit bien qu là pour le coup ça peut
expliquer une partie des hausses de
taxes foncières il ya des collectivités
qui sont en difficulté et c'est là pour
le coup c'est vrai parce que la hausse
des carburants parce que la hausse des
marchés publics liés à la hausse des
matériaux les met en difficulté mais ne
ne disons pas par pitié que c'est à
cause de la taxe d'habitation tout le
monde sait que ça a été compensée à
l'euro l'euro on va parler de la réforme
des retraites là aussi c'est un sujet
qu'il ya quatre les français vous l'avez
emmanuel macron interpellé à de
nombreuses reprises là dessus alors
maintenant il dit que les l'âge légal de
départ à 65 ans n'est plus un dogme
qu'il peut y avoir une clause de
revoyure à la fin de son quinquennat que
pour le moment il va il va prolonger la
durée de cotisation de quatre mois tous
les ans on comprend pas bien est ce que
dans la loi il y aura un âge légal de
départ inscrits et lequel c'est c'est
d'abord un il a dit qu'il était prêt au
dialogue dans la propre dans la
construction de la loi et donc non dans
l'âge de idy thiam un clause de revoyure
parce que la clause de revoyure elle
sert à quoi elle sert à voir ce qu'on a
eu des tas de d'anticipation du comité
d'orientation des retraites qui parfois
nous disait on va dans le mur parfois
nous disait on va pas dans le mur
parfois nous re disait qu'on allait dans
le mur
manifestement il ya besoin de pouvoir en
continu regarder les faits sur les
choses de il est sur quelque chose qui
l'avait dit depuis le début c'est tous
les ans quatre mois de plus voilà est
donc dans le débat à regarder si ces 64
ou 65
il maintient l'idée qu'il faut augmenter
l'âge de départ légal légal de la loi
mais laissons faire le lit là il a dit
qu'il rentrerait dans le dialogue en
tout cas il a assumé l'idée qu'il
faudrait travailler plus longtemps y
compris pour financer je le dis dès
minimum retraite à 1100 euros pour tout
le monde y compris pour financer dès le
mois de juillet quatre à quatre et demi
pour cent d'augmentation des pensions de
retraite donc à un moment quand on
commence à dire voilà ce qu'on va faire
et voilà ce sur quoi on s'engage en
termes de revalorisations des retraites
en termes de
d'aider ceux qui ont les carrières les
plus difficiles ceux qui sont en dessous
de 800 euros c'est quand même mis 100
euros il ya pas pourquoi beaucoup vivre
avec 1100 euros donc c'est bien le
minimum qu'on doit aux français
évidemment il découle donc il faut
augmenter la durée de la durée 64 ou 65
le débat a permis le dialogue permettra
64 ou 65 et quel que soit le choix fait
de dire on a une clause de revoyure pour
voir si on n'a juste pas c'est à dire
d'avoir un mécanisme qu'en permanence ça
juste ou en continu s'ajuster que devant
les français en dise on augmente ça si
on prend la part de responsabilité
contrairement aux je le dis au passage à
madame le pen qui fait croire qu'elle ne
change rien et qui au fond hamel les
gens plutôt vers 67 que vers un âge
légal c'est-à-dire que en augmentant la
durée de cotisation en maintenant la
durée de cotisation sans âge limite elle
met les gens en situation de partir
assez tard à la retraite et donc c'est
pas notre volonté donc on augmente
jusqu'à 64 65 c'est le débat qui
produira les éléments et puis de clause
de revoyure est par ailleurs un certain
nombre d'engagements qui ont été pris
devant les français en termes de
revalorisations sur le minimum retraite
et sur une revalorisation générale des
retraites au mois de juin j'oserais dire
quelque chose aussi c'est qu'au moment
où on parle de ces questions là le
président de la république sont ils
prêts ça a été aussi le président parce
que il ya le projet piller le bilan ça a
été un président qui a été au rendez
vous des promesses qu'il avait faites
devant les français ya cinq ans c'est
important pour le crédit politique de le
faire non mais en général sur la
revalorisation d'un certain nombre de
prestations la lutte l'allocation adulte
handicapé les minimums que personne
n'avait fait et dont je nous avons
quelque chose d'assez fort devant les
français à dire c'est que nous nous
avons tenu des engagements qui étaient
ceux devant nous alors on n'a pas pu
aller au bout sur la réforme des
retraites c'est vrai mais en tout cas
sur d'autres on va parler de la question
de la proportionnelle vous allez vous
allez je pense que c'est important
devant les français de dire que quand on
fait des ondes tient on prend des
engagements on essaie de les tenir et
c'est ce que nous avons fait pendant
cinq ans on peut en parler on va parler
de la question des institutions pareil
vous étiez engagé à une part de enfin
emmanuel macron s'était engagé une part
de proportionnelle elle n'a pas eu lieu
là c'est pareil on comprend pas bien est
ce que il est pour une proportionnelle
intégrale le président et c'est ce que
j'ai entendu en disant que lui il était
pour mais que simplement ils attendent
et qui est un dialogue et un débat
comment dirais-je devant la nation sur
ces sujets là pour essayer de trouver un
consensus je ne remets à la
proportionnelle intégrale oui mais
proportionnelle intégrale pardon devant
nous tous qui écoute on ça veut pas bon
c'est pas prévu ça veut tout et rien
dire pour personnel intégral c'est une
circonscription nationale c'est une
circonscription régionale en 86 la
proportionnelle intégrale était
départementale ça n'a pas du tout les
mêmes effets électoraux une
proportionnelle intégrale dans un
département un député voyez bien que la
diversité politique va pas être
représentés de la même façon que si
c'était une proportionnelle intégrale à
577 donc le principe général me semble
être le bon après faut regarder les
modalités il me sens que je
vais vous dire ce qui est adapté aux
institutions c'est que enfin l'ensemble
des opinions puissent être présentés à
l'assemblée nationale et que deux ans on
puisse trouver des voies et moyens des
compromis je note avec
vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas de même
nature selon la nature de la
proportionnelle intègre au pav je vois
bien le procès qui est fait pour éviter
d'avancer sur ce sujet depuis alors
c'est intéressant si madame le pen a
changé d'avis sur le sujet la question
est une sorte de tradition c'est d'avoir
mais ça veut rien dire de tir un tiers
ça veut dire qu'on leur découpe les
circonscriptions excusez moi il ya un
moment pour rentrer dans le dur du sujet
je pense que je le connais de tirah
tierces et les circonscriptions
réservées en proportionnelle où c'est à
la fin voilà le résultat qu'on veut et
pardon de vous dire alors je trouve
intéressant dans le monde en convient et
moi je n'ai pas changé d'avis depuis 25
ans c'est que des partis politiques qui
était très opposé à la proportionnelle
compte tenu des résultats électoraux du
10 avril commence à trouver et à
retrouver toutes les vertus de la
proportionnelle moi je ne change pas
d'avis au gré des élections et ce n'est
pas parce que nous sommes en situation
où nous pourrions donner à voir une
envie de domination que moi je ne
respecte pas l'idée que je me fais de la
politique et celle que la diversité des
opinions puissent être présentés à
l'assemblée nationale et donc faut
trouver des modalités qui permettent de
le faire alors je répète une chose aussi
c'est crois pas que la question
institutionnelle se résume à la question
proportionnelle la question
institutionnelle et démocratique c'est
aussi une question d'attitude la manière
dont on essaie de chercher le compromis
dans sa majorité et avec les oppositions
est bien aussi c'est un chemin sur
lequel nous devons nous mettre questions
sur les propositions de marine le pen
sur la constitution elle veut modifier
la constitution marine le pen pourrait
faire entrer la priorité nationale ou
encore le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et elle dit qu'elle je
voudrais qu'elle veut que la
modification si elle est élue que la
modification de la constitution ne passe
que par le peuple c'est à dire plus par
le parlement qu'en pensez-vous bas c'est
juste je crois que tout le monde l'a dit
on tout ça que ceux qui sont attachés au
c'est juste que nous lie la constitution
et que la constitution et la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
ne dis pas ça donc elle dit quelque
chose qu'elle ne pourra pas faire ce qui
est ennuyeux quand des ce qu'on appelle
un mensonge quand vous savez que vous
faites une proposition qui ne passe pas
la rampe je rappelle que c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui est juge de
la constitutionnalité d'un référendum
continûment alors je ne je ne préempte
pas ce que dirait ce qu'à dieu ne plaise
le conseil constitutionnel dans cette
configuration là mais c'est tout le
monde sait que ça ne marche pas alors
elle se pare de dire le général de
gaulle l'a fait il ya 60 ans très bien
mais sauf qu'on nous sommes dans une
autre époque et depuis lors une
jurisprudence a pu se construire donc je
crois que le président larcher je crois
que des constitutionnalistes de façon on
entre toujours un constitutionnaliste et
une autre idée enfin globalement ceux
qui connaissent un peu les sujets
constitutionnel 10
disent que ça ne marche pas et que donc
c'est une promesse qui ne marche pas et
puis par ailleurs on peut pas à la fois
dire je suis attaché au parlement est
passé par dessus le parlement alors
c'est pas facile de trouver un compromis
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
j'en sais quelque chose enfin je pense
que la démocratie trouverait grandement
son compte et j'espère que dans le débat
que nous aurons sur la question
institutionnelle de toute façon
sénat et assemblée nationale se mettront
d'accord s'en sortant de l'esprit
parfois des tanks et l'opposition la
majorité qui est on pense à sa boutique
et pas au reste j'espère qu'on trouvera
ce chemin là est la dernière question de
christophe oui alors marc fesneau doit
votre circonscription
bruxelles le siège de député à caen
depuis l'été dernier puisque votre
suppléant stéphane beaud lui a choisi de
se consacrer à ses mandats locaux est ce
que vous vous serez candidat en juin je
dirai les choses dans les semaines qui
viennent parce que moi je prends je suis
un peu besoin de pardon de le dire comme
ça et je dirai les choses dans les
semaines qui viennent une fois
l'élection présidentielle passée vous
vous imaginez que j'ai une petite idée
mais je pense que d'abord ce coup tordu
pardon attendait pardon de le dire ainsi
c'est pas après vous non plus c'est pas
paris je le dirai ce que je dis
oui oui par le biais du mais j'irai
peut-être au siège de la nouvelle
république dire un certain nombre de
choses ou ailleurs d'ailleurs eux
je n'ai jamais me suis jamais dérobé aux
combats électoraux mais je pense les
combats les uns après les autres jamais
présentées les combats et les débats les
uns après les autres et donc
comme député puis comme ministre avec
jacqueline gourault d'ailleurs on n'a
cessé de se préoccuper de ce qui était
les questions du loir et cher quand il y
avait des sujets économiques quand il y
avait des sujets industriels quand il y
avait des sujets de collectivités est
une préoccupation principal c'est
d'essayer d'apporter avec mes
compétences avec mon parcours avec la
place où je serai et où je suis
d'apporter des choses au département et
je lui dois bien ça donc c'est dans les
impatiences ne sera pas trop longue que
je sais que vous n'êtes pas très
impatient christophe
question derniers mois sur les
législatives puisque jean luc mélenchon
vous l'entendez l'huile mais déjà le cap
sur les législatives il appelle les
français j'avais dit mais d'abord le cas
pour faire en sorte que ma on peut pas à
la fois mettre le cap sur législatives
et bail passé le le sujet dimanche parce
que quand il dit peu importe pardon je
le dis si c'est marine le pen ou
emmanuel macron je pense que peu importe
pas ils ne sont que avant de passer là
aussi de passer au sujet suivant je
pense que le sujet c'est d'essayer
d'éviter une aventure folle qui serait
celle de l'élection de madame ben
comment on se trompe il finira pour vous
dans un entre-deux tours présidentielle
commençait à dire après avoir faire
s'est il pas une voix pour madame le pen
dire si c'est madame le pen ou monsieur
mélenchon sur ma condition là qu'on peut
importe je idylle inverse de ce qu il a
dit le soir du premier tour bon c'est
dommage c'est comme ça j'en prends acte
et par ailleurs le débat législatif
vient après et par ailleurs si son sujet
c'est à chaque fois d'être dans comment
je peux faire pour faire blocage bon il
fait il fait l'effet de la politique il
a le droit j'avais compris qu'il était
plutôt à dire qu'il sortait du jeu
manifestement il rentre dans le jeu très
bien près pas de problème
c'est pas le sujet je pense qu'on aura
un débat intéressant sur les
législatives je pense que c'est un débat
qui qui doivent actuellement la question
de il faut donner une majorité emmanuel
macron c'est une majorité qui porte un
certain nombre de priorités et envie de
faire et de changer des choses c'est là
dessus qu'il faudra faire le débat et
pas simplement pour savoir qui va être
premier ministre même si c'était
monsieur mélenchon qui souhaitait l'être
et vous reviendrez évidemment parler
hâtive marché nous en tout cas on
pourrait invitera avec plaisir regardez
la nouvelle république mais c'est vous
marque renault la nouvelle république
dernières heures de campagne voilà
c'était à la une de la nouvelle
république merci christophe janvry et
merci beaucoup c'est que ce soit vrai
nom d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]